so i got a couple of questions i think i
remember the first one
yeah so you know when you're talking
about this jumper this lifestyle that
you have yes yes yes
yes you wanna jump on it was really
uncomfortable for you but you wanted to
look good in it
yes were you born with that jumper no
yeah and then this life made you
uncomfortable
no basically i was living a lifestyle
for example
clubbing cars money all that kind of
stuff
yeah so i had i bought a specific jumper
i would like to look after myself i
would like to look nice and the reason i
would like to look nice is so i can have
the attention of woman i would go gym so
i can have attention of woman
i would one second one second i would
drive certain costs of the attention of
a
woman
i was enslaved to my society yeah i
found true freedom by breaking those
shackles
and bringing a slave to the one who
created me because i believe by nature
all of us are born to be enslaved to
something
so you can tell me you can't tell me
that how you
may dress and this is you can dress up
however you like how you're dressed
and the way you behave and the lipstick
or whatever all of that you cannot tell
me
that that is not societal pressure no no
no i'm not saying that but i'm just
addressing your comparative
is it wrong i'm addressing your jumper
life comparative right
yes so you compared this uncomfortable
jumper
yes to your life you wore the jumper
your previous one right yeah so you wore
the jumper because you looked good in it
yes
but i thought i did anyway yeah i mean
why it depends on each other that's an
outside opinion yes yes
subjective um you said you wore this
jumbo because you looked in it but
you sacrificed what you wanted to do you
sacrificed your comfort
yes for looking good yes yes do you not
also think
that by giving yourself up to god which
is not no longer a jumper it's a cage
yeah it is a cage because you were
saving this life right
okay okay yeah you've given up your
freedom completely
so you you could have taken off that
jumper and worn a more comfortable one
yes you know become okay good okay i get
a question you're saying ali
you're saying that you've left one kind
of slavery but but for example
waking up for fajr yeah is hard
it's very hard yeah um going about
staying away from a promiscuous
dinner yeah all that kind of thing is
hard yeah especially at a time where we
live
where getting married is hard that's why
i have a whole marriage documentary
based on that
to share my thing yeah okay
that's the reason why i talk about my
struggles yeah inshallah of course
it comes out yeah so now what you're
saying is this brother ali
is that not the same as your enslaved
yourself
my jumper and society and women or
whatever
they do not deserve me to be a slave to
them what i'm saying
i'm asking you a question no no no no no
i was and so are you
and so was everyone you were or you are
but i'm not saying that you have to be a
slave to anyone
i'm saying no you you gave away one
slavery for another that is what i'm
saying
that's what i'm trying to answer one
deserves it because he's the one who
created me
one is created by men do you understand
the difference
if i come and say this book controls my
life
i free myself from this and go to my
lord
he is deserving of my enslavement
what is he deserving of yours because
he's madam who brought you to this age
my parents okay does your parents
deserve some kind of respect
uh my father tried to kill me so well
let's talk about good parents then let's
talk about good parents yeah
a good parent yeah that looks like give
your respect
your love yeah affection mercy
presence yeah check on holidays good
okay
so now if i come and say to you why do
they deserve it why don't you just stay
focused again
they raised you but god did not raise
you god is the one who gave
god is the one who made the ones you
raised you yeah so they raised me
sister by the way i want to apologize
again sorry i i i
okay okay sorry once again sorry i just
had a little heated discussion
yeah and sometimes you speak this kind
of when you have heated discussions and
you have another conversation
you carry that on so forgive me i'm
standing a bit aggressive yeah
no sorry sorry no forgive me forgive me
if i've come across sorry i just need to
reset my
factory settings okay
sister what i'm trying to say is this
yeah if your parents deserve the love
affection the mercy and all that kind of
stuff the one who's made your parents
deserve
more than that so what i'm saying sister
is this yeah
you claim to be an ex-muslim yeah okay
if i ask you certain questions
would you be able to answer them is this
is this the ex-muslim test yeah kind of
you're going to give me the x-muslim
test yes ali yeah
you're really going to do that i really
am okay you can ask i don't know if i
know
okay what i'm going to do is this sister
yeah i'm not going to ask i'm going to
assume the best
person no i'm not going to ask i'm going
to you could you can ask i'm pretty good
i'm not going to ask no you don't know
what i'm going to ask
no give us the questions i've already
agreed
okay all right okay how long was you
were muslim for so then my question is
muslim a proper muslim prophet muslim
for about
10 years 10 years okay what is the
difference between an
award and a
okay because the reason i've asked you
how long you was because if you was for
one year
i wouldn't ask you this question because
this is something that you would find
out
you should find at the beginning but it
will take a bit of time yeah i mean i've
been away from islamic studies
i'm not saying that but the thing is i
have the question
so for example so for example suffer if
someone works in a ferrari uh
factory yeah and once he doesn't know
how to make a ferrari and he goes i left
the ferrari factory shop because they
build the rubbish
the problem is within the person itself
not with the factory
let me just look at them okay how many
how many how many how many how many
cars for fragile yeah
to work in a ferrari company yes you
need to have experience
you don't need to have experience to
become a muslim okay
is that not true yeah i'll just give you
even if someone who
has lived their whole life as a
non-muslim yeah and then accept your
father on the deathbed
yes yes
let me tell you why because the issue
here is this we have a lot of people
that come and claim to be an ex-muslim
when we ask them surah fatih they go
what is that
okay no but this is what i'm saying
that's the reason why we ask because
there's a lot of people
who claim are christian uh missionaries
they lie so we just do that to show and
prove
yeah now sister
it's going to catch it yeah what i'm
saying is this sister here
is that do you understand the example i
gave if god has created you
no no i fully understand the exact okay
okay do you believe in god uh
i don't know where i am with god right
now okay what made you
leave this now what made me leave islam
yes uh
i know that from your videos because
i've watched a couple of them you assume
that it's from
an emotional reason not all the time all
the time if i'm completely honest
yes it is from an emotional reason okay
i thank you for your honesty yeah but do
you believe that emotional reasons
aren't valid when it comes to accepting
or leaving religion
look let me put it like this here i will
have like
i see you like a sister in humanity yeah
what is the
nice um coffee drop there yeah so i need
to clean it
look let me have a bit of a
heart-to-heart with you like you're my
sister you see me like your brother yeah
yeah when i look around the world and i
see innocent people suffering when i see
grenfell
when i see it hurts me as a person it
hurts me
emotionally i do sometimes say why
why does this happen yeah now the
question is this sister my
emotions and what's going on and i gave
this example to a brother yeah
i said that there was this guy i was
talking to you yeah
we look at the syrian boy his family has
been blown into pieces we say god
doesn't exist
if god exists this wouldn't happen but
the funny part
no no you know if i'm saying that
certainly but what is more profound
is the one who's being bombed
it's says it doesn't make it true let me
tell you
what i'm trying to make is a point here
the one who's been bombed on
his conviction allah grows the one who's
seeing it
emotionally says now forget that god
doesn't exist i find the scenario
interesting because the one whose
family's been blown into pieces
says i'm not using this as an argument
to say islam is a true or not
i'm seeing from an emotional perspective
he should be more emotional and asking
more questions than you
or me i'm talking about myself it's not
necessarily true because one is dying
and one is is it and one is scared
for what happens after he does one one
is suffering one is not
but my question is that do you think
that emotions are invalid when it comes
to leaving
or joining i would say for somebody to
leave islam
based on emotions all that shows
is that that person had an emotional
scenario situation and took it out on
islam and left
it does not negate that islam is false
so for example i'm not saying no that's
what i'm saying that's what i'm saying
sister so
these certain people who claim to be
ex-muslims yeah
some of them are genuine don't get it
twisted i've never said that all of them
are fake
no some of them are fake like grid one
yeah doesn't even know the six pillars
of a man
yeah yeah yeah yeah but there's some
that are genuine so
sister what emotional reason did you
meet before let's discuss that because
that indeed
i want good for you i'm sure you weren't
good for me really long story honestly
it only happened like very fresh so i
don't really want to cry on
all these clowns okay okay dude do you
mind if we had that discussion maybe
with all of us we'll go and eat
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay let's
let's go
like around nine o'clock yeah maybe a
few sisters can come as well if they
like they can sit with you
i'm here not now not now i'm i'm here
till night
okay so if you guys then because
obviously it's something that
we we we feel your pain don't get it
twisted then we don't hate you i think
you get it
no no we make that bridge but we make it
with people who are genuine
okay i'm not going to make this bridge
with redwan the fake
clown no i would attack redwan the clown
is he's a fake
clown who insults the prophet he doesn't
i'm defending for himself yeah he's a
clown and
he has no defense no no if he's evildoer
yeah he's a boy
you know like hijab says yeah you're
finished you're finished it is backed by
no no he's someone who insults online
his message i like that woman where is
she
she she was swearing out allah i turned
my back on and i put you in your place
she starts crying
you insult allah i turn my back against
you when i say i put you in your place
she starts crying where'd she go
around about someone without them being
here that is backed by him
well what about somebody talking about
my religion
yeah my prophet not hearing okay my
prophet is not here to defend himself
but even even if he's back fighting in
front of him not about
back biting he's not for evil dude it's
actually you might get good
good deeds for black bites in that
evildoer that's not genuine that is
genuine that is not genuine islamically
you can stand up not a muslim you can
back bite them no i just said not a
muslim i said
somebody who's the enemy of allah okay
so someone who is an enemy yes i'll back
by happy days all day all night
all day all right problems i'm not sure
that that's where your profit free no no
look my
my prophet for example the first one
would he talk
to evil no would he ask but the issue
here is this
in certain circumstances you can back by
how if i
if if somebody wants to marry my brother
i'm going to say look
my brother is not a good man i'm not i
know that there are exceptions that's
what i'm saying that's what i'm saying
he's not here and you're back fighting a
process no it's not it's not like sister
it's not i'm telling you stomach
is not bad he's the enemy of islam who
insults the prophet
i believe he's an animal he's a clown
he's i i don't i don't want to drop to
his level
he's an absolute clown you are doing
that the least i can do is call him a
clown
i